fora tv' the world is thinking
[Music]
good evening this is a long now
foundation event my name is Stuart brand
thank you for overflowing this wonderful
theatre I should mention that later this
month we have another speaker craig
Venter who may also draw a large
audience especially because he's
creating life these days and in a sense
this is a second in a series of talks
about thinking about the future only the
speaker tonight says it's not the future
that he talks about but I'll bet that
many of us interpret it that way
the last speaker was Paul Sappho who is
here tonight Paul talked about
techniques of forecasting especially in
technology and sort of in the decade
range of time in a sense he's looking at
the future in a micro scale in context
of the long now foundation where we like
to think of the last 10,000 years in the
next 10,000 years decades are pretty
quick in that period of time large
events have a way of happening and so
the speaker tonight is talking about the
macro scale and macro events
please welcome Nassim Taleb
so my talk is not definitely gonna be
our bloody future I know nothing about
the future first of all let me show you
the picture of the book the American
Statistical Association has a special
session on the Black Swan and that's
what they're gonna do with my book in
August and Colorado I have to show up to
be yelled at the the Black Swan what is
the Black Swan first of all it's not
this wine and let me explain to you that
people as part of our like inability to
think to do second order thinking most
people buy me this wine not thinking
that other people are aware the Black
Swan wine affected right Black Swan so
please if I ever invite you to dinner or
some piece for Christmas I just had an
email today from students at Harvard
they want to piss off their professors
by by inviting me of course they and
they said we're gonna have reception and
and and they mentioned this wine okay so
it's not is undrinkable so what's the
Black Swan no no honestly typically the
red wine what's the Black Swan before
the discovery of Australia we had no
reasons to believe that swans could be
of any other color but white or people
in the old world and effectively there
was a an expression in medieval England
you'd sooner see a Black Swan then say
for example it was just like saying when
pigs fly or when when when I don't know
there's something intelligent or
something also needs the exceptions so
there was an expression until we saw
Australia and effectively one the
sighting of a single bird destroyed
millennia of confirmation so it was a
post as a logical problem by showing
that there's no reason you cannot rule
out a Black Swan because you haven't
seen any
okay my problem is not a logical
question my Black Swan is an event it's
not a bird so and it's an event that has
three properties the first property it
is hard to predict very difficult to
predict based on information
understanding the right spot okay
based in on information before its
occurrence prior information based on
historical information you have here a
sample of black swans the most
interesting one is the tie
someone's gonna forecast the future at
the forecast that human beings 2,000
years away would constrict their blood
supply with this device for example okay
and attend meetings okay so that's very
difficult to predict the computer was a
Black Swan it changed the world and
nobody thought the computer could do
anything you know it was initially used
for communist oryx I mean the Watson
from IBM did not think that this tool
could have any use the rise of religions
likes one totally unpredictable
Harry Potter has a black swan a lot of
cultural phenomena are black swans the
to me the most significant black swan
and the one I'm going to focus next few
minutes is the first war the first war
we had after Napoleon we saw for about a
hundred years that the world became
civilized and that you know people
became conscious of the need for peace
and you had this devastating war the
biggest war something was destroyed and
of course it came in two volumes you had
Volume one and then had sequel so so
here we have black swans
events of low predictability high
consequence but the most vicious part is
the following one is that before the
fact they're extremely predictable but
after the fact you know what we saw him
coming
so we have this is what I call the
retrospective there's the distortion if
these events are prospectively
unpredictable retrospectively
predictable why we even have disciplines
to make us to give us the illusion of
understanding of the world you say have
disciplines that make us misunderstand
the world by giving us this illusion of
private ability history for example
economics other such things
astrology okay so we have and what
what's the mechanism by which we sort of
like have the solution understanding the
world the first one is what I call
silent evidence before people think that
the first war was predictable
particularly if you are gonna if you
have been to school high school and they
discuss the first war it appears to
result from tension between the UK on
one hand Austria and Germany on the
other okay so you think that there is
tension let to worry if you see tension
then you can predict for that you're not
looking at Ephesus of tension that did
not lead to war and there were a lot of
episodes of tension before that that did
not lead to war and these episodes
usually led to parties in Baden Baden
you see was opera saying there's a lot
of champagne and they get drunk all
right Kings get drunk plus they know
each other
so you have to realize that after the
war things tension causes war but if
you're in a champagne business you
realize think tension causes you know
drunkenness by kinks when they make up
okay so we have that problem so let me
give you an illustration of this
inability we have in looking at what I
call the silent evidence of pool of
evidence that did not lead to the same
result the comment made this is recorded
know even better my comment made by
publisher about the success of the Black
Swan and he was explaining it as follows
look it has an animal and the color on
the cover explains the success
now okay this is so I went when I heard
that I said okay plane I'm gonna take
care of this guy I looked on Amazon for
how many books have animals and colors
on the title and uncover that ended up
flopping okay and you had plenty of him
I found 69 books with a Black Swan and
their titles okay that were flops you
don't hear if you don't hear about him
is because it flops we're not looking at
evidence plus of course you have
permutation pink elephant different
colors different animals okay so plenty
plenty of book like that that flock so
this is what I call the cemetery of
evidence and for those of you interested
in probability it's a big probability
problem because we compute probability
based on those who survived
probabilities of survival not based on
the pool of those who started it so this
is very endemic in a way we analyzed the
world the way to understand information
is what we perceive information
decision-making under uncertainty is
completely dominated okay with this
mistake of taking a pool of information
and excluding the rest so it's what I
call silent evidence what we have it on
Wall Street you look at the winners and
say they have skills and don't look at
people are the same sets of skills who
ended up losing because these people
don't read biographies you see they
don't say how I lost a million dollars
tell you how they made it so you have
that so and then
but the problem is historians you know
people on Wall Street you can understand
that they're not that smart but
historians did not know that okay or did
not deal with it empirically now I
happen to have spent 18 years as a
trader and I hated it okay but I stayed
there because it was fun particularly
because he had economists around and
people who make forecasts and could make
fun of them so there was some some some
there was some advantages to it but one
thing I discovered is that when you work
with Beauty the power of economics is
that we have 20 of data when you have
data you can do some
some real analysis on the data that's
completely unbiased because the data is
going to be there and you can throw
numbers at as a computer so I looked at
history to see if anybody did something
like that and it discovered that one of
your future speakers Neil Ferguson a
brilliant man and I recommend if you
ever want to have lunch fun lunch with
someone to call him up if you know he's
good lunch right so he is and he wrote a
paper showing that although we believe
that the first war was predictable bomb
the bond market there's something called
war bonds in UK and the bond UK mom did
not predict it so cannot be that
predictable if the bond market nobody
told you know the bond market okay so we
have have prediction markets and stuff
like so so we realized now when you run
if you dig into history how bad we are
at predicting how bad we are at seeing
things how bad our predecessors were at
predicting but a mechanism of course is
called over causation I skip this
because it's too complicated
but there's another there's a also
there's some psychological mechanisms
involved that you make an actual
prediction you have the outcome and then
all right
this is remembers predictions back ok
I've sat down what you remember
typically that you remember you remember
having predicted is more consistent with
what you observed so you don't remember
what you're actually predicted but you
revised your memory of what you actually
predicted continuously to make it
consistent with current events not only
you do that with your prediction we also
do that with your intentions which is a
big problem and for us in the trusting
because you would realize that if we
didn't have this effects people would
know that they're very bad at predicting
economics Department would be empty
commit suicide or something like that
you would have no no social science to
speak of ok people would turn cab
drivers or something so you would
realize but but that
it's a it is a psychological bias now
let me talk about the Black Swan problem
in in history okay in in in philosophy
and and and I'm going somewhere with
this particularly with my next next work
the first gentleman up there on the left
the one who's little horizontally
challenged his name is Hume okay
it's called humans problem but it's not
his problem it's because he wrote in
English is great ideas write in English
then it should be remembered what people
who write in English that it's
effectively he took it from someone else
but Hume is worthy discussing because he
was completely annoyed was a Black Swan
problem completely annoyed with that
problem of induction it was not called
Black Swan I thought it was called the
problem of generalizing from finite
sample or problem of induction and what
he did with it is very simple he said
you know what I leave it for the
philosophical cabinet and in real life I
can't deal with it he was a party animal
and his reaction to the Black Swan
problem is to become even more
horizontal you see which he gained a lot
of weight and then he died and he had a
happy life in Edinburgh in Paris in
Edinburgh okay
so let's forget about him because it
could be no help except also to
illustrate one thing that happened in
philosophy is that increasingly
philosophers became what I call domain
dependent is they're good at talking
about a problem in a classroom and then
they forget about it when they leave the
classroom and it's a bias that addition
for example not understand statistics in
real life the good in front of the
blackboard we know that from a lot of
experiments the way I I discuss it in
the Black Swan as I talk about that for
that domains of the dependence about the
reebok Club in New York where people go
get in their gym clothes and then take
the the the elevator to the to the stair
masters and then get on stairmasters and
log their 112 floors stories and then
stop and then take a lot of it ok so you
have domain dependence because not
recognizing it's something indexer of
real life so let's forget it this guy
next to him there is a french guy but
the French don't know about him
or at least for Caliban want to forget
about it he is a bishop called
Bowie and he dealt with a Black Swan
problem by becoming extremely religious
he not liking science and of course we
had the Enlightenment that became bro
science and with all the tragedies that
we have coming from it and so he is
forgotten
he became very religious the gentleman
here is al gazelle
he was the Arabic see the Arabic
language I mean the sorry the Arabs
calling an Arab the Persians call him a
Persian so he's a Arabic language
philosopher who attacked the classical
philosophers by writing a treatise
called the on the incoherence of
philosophy very famous stratus and he
created Sufi Islam out of his thing so
his blacktron problem led these two
gentlemen to become extremely religious
now the one on the right is my hero or
you know I think we don't really know if
he existed or if you know but what he
represents would make him my hero is sex
this America's he's not and philosophy
books not very common philosophy books
he was he had two things he was a
skeptical gentleman who phrased the
problem induction just the way Hume
later on repeated it second century BC
ad and his second attribute he was a
doctor so there was a school of medicine
of decision maker on the makers under
uncertainty called the empirical doctors
who were damn good doctors they did not
like theories did not like to generalize
did not like to extend and to
unobservable okay they're not like to
make an you know go from from what they
know to what they don't know extremely
careful they call themself and persist
they did not like to generalize and
these before extremely successful
unfortunately they were completely you
know what medicine became intellectual
rationalists that we saw the understand
human body so these people were out of
business for about 15 centuries before
medicine came back the other barbers
okay their ideas can and if you guys are
alive today it's because these guys with
their ideas or because Barbara is not
because of intellectual doctors the
contribution of intellectual doctors
finally there's a gentleman who you
recognize him tickle if you live in
Berkeley all right Karl Marx all right
so Karl Marx had this idea one thing he
wanted you know in his thesis on fear
Bob he wanted to say he said the
philosophy you know was just talk let's
do something with it unfortunately but
so his idea was to turn knowledge into
action so my idea is that opposite how
to turn lack of knowledge and lack of
understanding into action so this is
pretty much my talk and how not to be a
turkey in the Black Swan this is my
cousin who did this story of the turkey
and the Black Swan you have the turkey
is in my book the Black Swan turkeys fed
for a thousand days every single day
confirms to the turkey that that butcher
is extremely or the human race in
general is extremely interested in its
welfare increasingly until of course
when the Black Swan happens I'm
interested in stories of Turkey one
because it shows the Black Swan story
you know and the consequences of
inferring from observables but the other
one is that for the turkey it's a Black
Swan but for the butcher it's not a
Black Swan okay so Black Swan depends on
the set of knowledge you have now if
we're going to have an earthquake here I
mean you have to make contingencies all
right if there's going to be an
earthquake this following slide will
probably take care of you know what I
have to say right so make sure that you
listen to the next slide because it
summarizes my position on the Black Swan
the two provinces media pristine and
extremist an and by the way I thank
Chris Anderson for suggesting the name
extremists and I gave the manuscript I
had a nerdy name right and he suggested
something else and it was a cream Stan I
owe it to him right and so in mediocre
Stan the following properties hold let's
play this following start experiment say
we gather at thousand people randomly
from the planet okay and you bring him
here you put him on a scale small on
scale of course well it's made in
California scale extremely oil built
okay and make sure you have one
Frenchman but not more because people
standing next on all right so on a scale
and make it so you have them okay you
and you weigh them alright then
try to imagine the heaviest human being
you can think of who can still be called
a human being and add him or her to the
scale half thousand how much of the
total will he represent how much 0.3%
half a percent point three percent I
don't know
California typically and you know point
three percent the heaviest human being
on the planet would be nothing like this
from the total so in me or Christine is
following rule holds when your sample is
large exception can happen that they're
not going to be consequential to the
total so this is a domain I told me
you're cursed and that domain everything
you've learned in statistics or almost
everything you learn statistics applies
to mediocre Stan and it's called the law
of what large numbers okay that as your
sample becomes large you're not saying
Thorpe it also tells you can diversify
your portfolio it tells you why
insurance companies services someone
survived although they don't quite
survive that well okay it tells you a
lot of things about
without this supreme law of when you're
cursed and you would not have statistics
now this is a problem because if let's
take the very same sample of a thousand
people and you're gonna have people from
Rwanda in your sample the very same
sample and try to think of the heaviest
person you can think of who can still be
called it no sorry of the wealthiest
person you can think of can still be
called a person he is not far from here
I guess no all right he can still recall
the person with borderline no and add
them to the sample how much of the total
will he represent okay it'd be hundred
percent okay he works about sixty
billion dollars the remaining two
thousand will be words two million
dollars alright you have people from
beyond from there okay so the supreme
law of extremists and tells you to
follow whenever you take a large sample
a small number of observations in that
domain will represent a big share of the
total so we have two domains one that's
dominated by the exception extremists
and and one that's dominated by the
general by the mediocre by the central
by a lot of people the collective one
the collective dominates the other one
okay
very simple let's take compare income
dentist for example not that you will
not find a dentist who makes more money
than all the other dentists combined in
a book business what's her name
the lady she sells a lot of books right
okay that effect you have what you have
16,000 books published every year in the
English language of these 16,000 books
some years five books five to 25 books
represent half the sales so you have
concentration in extremists an and we're
moving from mediocre Stan to be
extremists and if you're paid by the
hour your mediocre Stan extremists an is
you guys are the epicenter of extremists
and okay you have Google stuff like that
it won't have happened without you know
someone who makes sales sandwiches could
not become the Google overnight okay you
cannot if you have demand itself
sandwiches and then you have demand for
two billion sandwiches I don't know if
Ortega has to do to deliver two billion
sandwiches but in in in the electronic
and an information age you can deliver
you know put a zero okay so you have a
different properties and extremists and
fairness social fairness of course is
more prevalent in media pissed and then
extremists and of course you have more
opportunities in extremist an but or the
illusion of opportunities extremists and
but you have a lot of unfairness because
you have a winner-take-all effect an
extremist on and the metaphor is the
story I use in a Black Swan is that of
Giacomo an Italian opera singer and they
don't have a Pavarotti yet Pavarotti is
- 75 years old
okay you don't have a you don't have a
way to store your voice the income of
opera singers okay it's not going to be
massively skewed because if you were and
you find yourself some little town and
you're okay right
so the guy from Milan is non-compete
with you and and and then they
discovered the all these technologies
right that destroyed Giacomo and and
helped Pavarotti
okay so the the for example Amer as a as
a writer I'm an extremist an because
every time one of you buys my book I
don't have to go to my hotel room and
write it and I
but if I were making sandwiches I'd have
to do that so the the properties of
extremists an are quite nasty in the
sense that one observation can destroy
the whole thing
one exception can destroy the whole
thing economic life is from extremists
and the metrics we have are not that
they're to extremists and so take the
companies in the u.s. you have what
twelve thousand listed companies between
a hundred and two hundred companies
represent half a cupful ization there's
this rule of 8020 Pareto's law 8020 it's
not 80/20 things in life are about 0.05
and 99.95 so this is and this is an
illustration of extremists and versus
media Christine the inequality is this
is on the left as mediocre Stan on the
right as extremists and so pretty sure
you stand here in the middle is on sway
to super extremist and you don't have
that with height so there are two kind
of randomness this is two kinds of
randomness and and they're not that I
mean this is about the different even in
California you you know you you you know
I can have someone say walk in here
eight feet tall you guys won't be
surprised I would be surprised but I
can't see someone walking in here two
billion feet tall but it was wealth with
with random variables that belong to it
so they're not the same animals okay so
when someone says this is an
approximation when is there something
called the Gaussian curve okay it's a
tool of extremists of majorca Stan and
there are other more statistical names
that you know belong to video Christine
when they say their approximation so as
much of an approximation as this plant
approximate a human okay there are large
qualitative differences now let me turn
on philosophers III get the stuff
whenever I hear the word uncertainty
principle as if it has anything to do
with uncertainty for a lotta reason
number one quantum mechanics is from
Madeo crest and that's the first one
and second one the uncertainty we have
in physics in that kind of uncertainty
in quantum mechanics is at least a
certain of all our certainties because
they average out you see which is the
reason why the stable has not haven't
been here all this time okay I've been
talking for twenty minutes and they will
did not move so the problem to me I'm
certainty on here someone is I was
trying to go to Lebanon and there's
always war and there's absolutely no
scheduled timetable for the end of the
war okay there was when they killed
Bhutto it was not scheduled all right
the the subprime crisis so the
uncertainty we have is macro uncertainty
it's so monstrous and people waste their
time talking about limits of knowledge
here when in fact when the limits of
knowledge are not consequential the
limits on the right are consequential
yes they don't think that these on the
rights have real limits that's why I get
I get very angry
another thing I called the work called
the ludecke fallacy to try to beg people
not to equate uncertainty with what you
see in games as casino number one
because casinos for mediocre Stan and
second one you don't know the real life
you know you don't know the problems in
the real life you don't know the casino
the sterilized probabilities most of
what we learn tickly in philosophy
probability comes from this stupid thing
so I called the occlude ik because I
learned that once you use a Latin or
Greek word for anything you could charge
a lot more for it so use ludecke there's
another reason okay because gamblers
fallacy is something else that belongs
to a Berkeley former Berkeley professor
almost verse key and Danny Kahneman did
but let me give you my polish joke so
I've written two non-technical books and
almost every other line I go on a rant
against what I call you know the ludic
fallacy or manifestation of known
probabilities till I received by mail a
copy of the Polish translation of my
book
and and and there's a passage in it so I
say have nothing to lose games how I can
angry when illustrators suggest a die to
put die online or look what was it right
so that's my photo stroke let's let's
how it looks like right so so so my idea
in the Black Swan is not like Hume to
say okay let me get horizontal alright
and forget about you know leave my
anxiety about the problem section it's
my idea and the Black Swan is so try to
get not to be the turkey and realize try
to get out of trouble so I think the
media post an extremist an is a good
start you worry about the Black Swan an
extremist and because it's consequential
so I already know how to worry about the
consequential and people keep down
mirror.you Talib worry too much you
cross the street tell them yes my idea
is unlike you I don't want to cross the
street
blindfolded because it looks like we
have a psychological problem we tend to
be tricking when we know about the risks
and overreact and most risk-taking and
society and this is you can see sir
experiments are taking not because we're
particularly courageous and have a lot
of bravado and and and but know the arts
no it's because we don't know the arts
or we don't know what's going on we
don't know what's taking these risks
think of bankers okay they're the most
incompetent probably prefer a
professional in history because I've
been capped off by the government's but
bankers are a they take a lot of risk
they think they're not taking risk if
they know the risks they're taking they
won't change it would become plumbers or
something else you say so they don't
have the temperament so it's not so a
lot of people take risks because they
blindfolded not because they are
conscious or they see what they're doing
this is classical and finance is that
you see frequently that their investors
letter when someone does well for about
and then every single metrics every
single metric in economics will give
them low risk profile for 12 years
all right and sure enough they at the
end they have that you know that letter
is very sound letter dear investor
surely these events as as much of a
surprise to us as they are to you and
and then okay and but you know I saw
letter sent by some folks in 1998 who
had pseudo Nobel in economics and I saw
the one sent recently I was a prime
there was no linguistic evolution the
same thing right gear investor so this
is what I've been fighting is this is a
typical illustration of the problem
production I want to try to avoid it
this is what you see in finance or in
and that's anything or you're going to
have this as a performance it's gonna be
dominated variation or dominated but
this is 20 years by small number of
observations always have that yet people
to chat about small variations all the
time I was talking to forget it to
Ferguson and and I got in my head that
maybe I should start thinking about
history so I went to the bookstores to
fill up with books of history history
ography we're thinking about doing some
way of dealing with randomness and
history by comparing McGilchrist and to
extremists and and if you were to do a
quantitative history like simplify
history to a simple quantity stochastic
process that would be quantitative on
top you would have Amedeo Christine type
history at the bottom you have an
extremist and pop history or most you
don't have a lot of moves but guess what
when you have a move is going to be
abrupt so most of the time nothing
happens and then you have big jumps
history jumps it doesn't crawl and that
was a statement I made in the Black Swan
and against everything that was known in
history Agra feel I don't do a all that
stuff next let me talk about the experts
this is gonna be in a subway in London
okay ignore experts okay some expert not
that other experts the not all experts
alright and we're going to see ya know
not not you're not the plumber alright I
plus you need the plumber okay let me
start with the mathematicians all right
I know I'm sure the planning
mathematicians here enough
a few would be insulted like to do okay
so I spent some time working with
mathematicians of randomness and of
course I made it the following discovery
one day when the gentleman was giving a
lecture of why mathematics were
important in society and he was going to
explaining how traffic lights were
optimized and so on for math and math is
great and a thought but what if we wrote
an anti history of mathematics number
one of where mathematics has not been
useful to society extremely destructive
and the second one is instances in which
society did not eat mathematics so
mathematics plays a very small role but
owing to self-serving biases they tell
you what they do for you so don't tell
you what they don't do for you it's like
politicians so we have the feeling that
they're important of all the space of
possible equations that we have the one
mathematicians can handle is minut so
what we do what they do is they want
something that can prove the number of
things we can prove or your theorems for
it's so small that mathematics is it's
very whatever can be mathematics or be
suspicious now we were spoiled in
physics they tell you look it works in
physics we were spoiled in physics
although you know that a lot of things
that have not been mathematize but how
much medicine
how about economics how about all these
other fields okay they give you this is
called a confirmation bias like
politicians they do tell you what they
did for you know or they do for you
comfort by the confirmation is trouble
for a lot of reasons first let me show
you this slide this is you know to see
it well yeah bunch of nuns okay and I
think they know the mathematicians know
about uncertainty the knowledge of
uncertainty resemble the knowledge of
these ladies about nightlife and fun and
partying honestly right so this and
having spent nine years working with
mathematicians they'll finally I gave up
and
and teaching creating transfer great
anxiety and mass PhD students and the
problem that this is very mechanistic
now so there is a big conflict between
probability we're dealing with non
observables and mathematics that
requires mechanistic mind look that
looks for certainties and most of the
mathematics we have for randomness it's
gonna be then focused on the ludic
fallacy on Majorca stan things that can
be easily mathematize and that's a
tragedy it is a tragedy because it is a
tragedy because you have this big wedge
between practice and and and this
perception of reality okay coming from
mathematics the other problem we have
okay I'll make it clear next few slides
is that we tend to tunnel when we
project the future so you tend to you'd
like to tunnel so you like to use
someone's tools to tunnel further
because otherwise you have anxiety so
when you project the future you project
something extremely narrow that
resembles projection of the present even
less crazy than the present okay and and
of course you don't realize you know
we're not crazy enough to imagine the
future I mean events that take place
whether if I discussed these black swans
and here 20 years before they happened
I'm sure that that someone was called an
ambulance and it was taking me away
because these scenarios will create a
reality delivers much crazy a scenario
then our mind can imagine so there's a
tunneling helped by mechanistic tools
but why why why why do we do that
why do we produce these measures of
uncertainty why do we like to produce
this measuring Authority well we have a
genetic or we have whatever we have that
we need to reduce our anxiety by using
metrics there's nothing wrong with
talking about uncertainty there's
something wrong about talking about
certainty to satisfy take novocaine or
take some or
have a drink okay it's better than
producer forecast if you want to lower
your anxiety and we'll see later when I
talk about the expert breaking down the
expert line when I was on Wall Street
the fun was to look at projections made
by economists you see lawyers are very
smart
you can't catch them because they're
slick and they always manage to give you
some vague answers about anything
economists they give you a forecast well
you go process it if you have a computer
you have coffee and you have a trainee
you can process the forecast to see if
if they if they work better than cab
drivers and they don't work better than
fact cab drivers and there is a
psychological explanation is the
forecast that worsens invented this or
the Express receipt in the past you had
to sweat to make a forecast now you
could just extend the self in drag good
names right you extend the self so you
go to year 2020 2043 you go as many
centuries as you want it doesn't cost
you much in the past it was it was Labor
so the other so there is this is framing
okay typically and once you see it on a
piece of paper start believing in it
it's what we call framing a person who
really caught these people with our
pants down is Philip tetlock who's
supposed to be here tonight and and Phil
tetlock did process all these and and of
course within the psychology of it when
I met Phil I just realized that hey you
know what we know all the psychological
biases but I then realized that there
was a very simple way to figure out
which domains we can forecast and which
domains resists forecasting and guess
what it's mediocre stand versus
extremists and domains that have the
property the randomness is mediocre
stand property we are good at
forecasting the acerola of the you know
when we deal with stars and so on our
errors are Gaussian okay and this is
what it discovers about the first
application is measurement errors and
you know as a strong me right so but
we're talking about anything social
anything where one single observation
can have massive consequences we're not
good at forecasting so mediocre stands
extremists and there is a tableau made
by a gentleman called Santo all right
where it looks like the know what versus
know how distinction works like a
souffle chef you know that he's an
expert but an economist I'm not sure or
as their expert definitely addressing
and looking like an expert but not
expert at delivering a service that they
claim to you know that's what I call the
for expert or pseudo expert so the not
now why do we listen to these people
well the first one is there's an old as
you know I'm sure you all know it don't
ask this plans woman all right Ernie
all right don't ask a barber
if you need a haircut okay so if you
can't ask someone it's profession so
there's a self-serving aspect of
professions and the second one is we
sent like empty suits which allowed me
you know to formulate the following rule
never take advice from someone wearing
suit and tie it works it lines up
perfectly to the middle post an
extremist and stinking it Lorex okay it
lines up to the for expert now there's a
lesson this is Robert rivers figured out
a something and it was very interesting
that was before the invasion of Iraq is
that if you have any plans to make war
to engage in war you don't know what's
going to happen but we're not good at
predicting wars because we didn't have
many wars in our genetic heritage we did
a lot of raids raisin polishing we're
good as we humans and and and he showed
how primates are very good at invading
territory killing all the males and
this kind of thing so it looks like
simple domains again the errors are
familiar crest and we're good at
forecasting complex domain we don't
understand we don't have the right
intuitions the link between action and
consequence it's not as visible errors
are can be monstrous and dominated by
extremes so so again Wars are from since
Napoleon words have been more and more
from extremists an small yet for example
if you want to invade Grenada again go
ahead no problem right ok if you want to
say China you don't have to all right so
you see the difference between between
simple and more complex domain and of
course we're going to take some advice
from Yogi Berra who said the future
ain't what it used to be ok big
philosopher random and he understood the
point about how we're gliding more and
more into some form of concentrated
disorder one one of the things I discuss
in my next book I studied religion a
little bit I don't believe in beliefs by
the way alright on a belief that we
humans use the police to act
I think the Leafs have some other
purpose but the problem that I find very
inconsistent and I don't know if some
Dawkins friends or these guys are here I
find extremely inconsistent to be
suspicious of the bishops okay here this
is an offered up service a more thorough
so these suspicious of the bishop and be
a sucker when when it comes to stock
market ok or listen to the economists I
don't understand what's metrics double
standard you using ok when you know it's
a Dawkins was saying that these guys
these people have double standards he's
talking about post modernists he said
anybody riding a plane to go to a
conference ok when they doubt the laws
of physics is a hypocrite to me
anybody invested in stock market who is
critical ok a religion is a hypocrite
you're either I mean that's my point is
there's nothing wrong about being
critical or volitional you gotta go all
the way by bu so what we happens is our
skepticism its domain dependent and
we're going to test it there's a very
easy metric for me to test scepticism it
took me a while to figure it out you
show things to see if people see false
patterns or not and we're gonna be
testing I have a little a lab in London
at London Business School was a Dan
Goldstein and we're gonna test to see if
religious people are most fooled by
randomness outside religion like vice
versa okay so it is it is the problem
substituting religion was CNBC stock and
some that you know that the stock market
analysts okay they're worse than nothing
a lot worse than nothing okay so there
is an inconsistency there and
incidentally I figured out one thing is
that medicine you know that medicine for
a long time we had an expert problem in
medicine you still have some expert from
in medicine medicine killed more people
than it saved particularly in the late
18th century late 19th century okay till
discovery penicillin
okay and why because of something I call
the illusion of control and if by going
to a doctor by going to a doctor you you
you you know you wanted to do something
going to a doctor to do something you
hurt yourself so going to a the Temple
of Apollo or something like that or any
foreign religion so long as it takes you
away from a doctor it's gonna be
beneficial for you alright so that's the
idea of alleged people don't this I had
a notion of religion that sort of
conflict with the rest to illustrate
what I mean by illusion of control
illusion of control is when you go to
the casino and and you see people wanted
to throw so it got a high number on a
die they saw it hard okay and they want
a low number the saw it soft okay
and this is the so this is another this
is a Council of Economic Advisers with
His Eminence there and they're all there
so and this is an exercise of illusion
of control okay all right so now we're
out of the funds section how many more
minutes do I have sorry let me get
technical here sorry
ten minutes okay all right so now let me
get into the the work at the boring
section right this may cause a lawsuit I
hope the gentleman here I'm here I'm
debating him tomorrow very nice
gentlemen since I'm not taking him I'm
attacking a statement let me talk about
probability for a while so it's going to
get more technical so called boring sec
if you wanted to leave and come back for
the drinks all right so this gentleman
made the following statement he said
these events that we saw last summer
should happen every 10,000 years
actually has three days in row his
answers have every 10,000 years if you
look at the gentleman you see that he's
so considerably he's considerably
younger than 10,000 years
so therefore where is he getting his
probabilities from okay not from
personal experience he definitely is
getting his probabilities from where
he's getting him from from a theory all
right
ah-huh so where do you see from
something in philosophy would call that
a priori there was an a priori it
doesn't come from any form of empirical
observation or anything and I don't know
10,000 years ago we were training I we
don't have the records if what they were
doing then and if they're training how
sophisticated they were what computers
are used so we have a problem with
claims made about small probabilities
because the smaller the probability the
less observable it is going to be the
more you're gonna rely on theory and
theory is going to be fragile let me add
something to that problem and that
problem I call it the telescope problem
okay
what matters is not the probability what
matters is the empathy event so if I
have a small probability of losing a
million dollars
okay I don't care about the probability
I care how much I lose all right so what
matters is you worry more if you have a
small probability of being in a plane
that crashes and if you have small
probability of not having an umbrella
and of the rain okay so it's not the
probability that you care about
it's the probably times the event the
magnitude of the event the pair
probability times pi times land on the
the the problem we witness here is that
the smaller the probability the more
confident they seem to be about that
pair Pi Lambda when in fact it's the
most unstable because the smaller the
probability the more error you gonna
have the higher the area gonna happen
the estimation of that probability you
see necessarily if it's much sent we
have smaller absolute number of
observations through had larger error so
therefore anybody talk to my small
probability doesn't know what it's
talking about literally okay or they're
not talking about probabilities they're
talking about something else I don't
know a religion or whatever it is okay
they're not talking about probably all
right so this is a problem even you know
that we have because that pair the the
higher that that triangle I call it PI
lambda becomes a lot more random I mean
to repeat the point it does a near flood
okay require a lot more than thousand
years observation okay but thousand-year
flood that's much more devastating son
hundred year flood you see so this is
this is a problem we have a probability
if I know the Federal Reserve you pay a
visit a let them know okay which brings
me to prediction markets very quickly
I'm going to go over the boring section
here people use the some idiotic
statement that we're good at predicting
number of be collectively better than
individually you know that we know some
got since Calton number of you know
beings in the drawer okay
the infer that we can predict
socio-political events
first statement you can see the
difference these are familiar crest and
your errors are not gonna be monstrous
okay the number of jellybeans here the
second one is that when you predict
probabilities it's much easier than
predict total contribution of the impact
you see if you have you know if you have
small probability of having Bill Gates
or super Bill Gates it makes a big
difference the prediction markets we may
be able to predict prediction markets
because it's a binary event there's no
consequences yes or no you say so
whether it's cream Stan or non-extremist
and maybe okay but even then you cannot
rely on the probability using these
prediction markets as probability look
at today today Hillary Clinton is she
was she was like what she had 70%
probability of you know she was trading
at 70% now she's trading at 50% so these
probably changed all the time how can
you rely on them as indicators like
people think that probabilities are like
the temperature we go have someone from
MIT and two Russians come in and we're
going to measure it and get the number
okay it's like temperature it's not like
temperature we don't measure it okay we
estimate it and even collectively we're
not better at it and there's things that
even collectively we'll never be able to
get because the properties are way too
complicated this is the problem I have
was using prediction markets we can use
prediction markets to predict how many
car crashes you're gonna have on a
highway maybe not for something more
complicated than that
second point I have with models versus
practice is a story that metaphor of the
ice cube that I discuss in the black
song I just realized we I tried to read
the black monkey I was bored and I
didn't like it but but I found that that
section needed some expansion right so
because it's I really you know what it's
a good idea to discuss the the if I the
problem of most theorists problem for
universities is you go from theory to
practice the degrees of freedom from
theories of practice are considerably
narrow small the reverse is monstrous so
let me give you this
for if I leave in a small piece of ice
cube on the floor okay you can easily
get someone in second year physics
students to write the equation to tell
you what's going hard to predict how
that ice cube will melt okay it's a very
simple thing the second rate student
could do it all right right know someone
from Boston that is can do it okay so
the yeah so you can you can you can
predict so but now conditional on seeing
water on the floor is it easy to
reverse-engineer the ice cube no you
have an infinity of ice cubes the
different shapes that can with have
January it's exactly going from theory
to practice versus practice to theory
given something you observe the
observable it generative observables and
uh no no no okay would be a theory you
have infinite number of theories that
can do that particularly when we are
dealing with nonlinearities when
particularly when it is nonlinear okay
in nonlinear where it varies let me give
you this metaphor this solution of
following doctrine the most intelligent
piece probably piece of work done on
following that induction since success
in Turkish if I have had these series of
dots up there
I ask you to extend them in the future
okay
with the linear model this is one step
one okay you can extend them from twenty
years and to eighty years if it's linear
you just take a ruler and extend it in
the future you agree now you're assuming
a saline your model AHA but if it's but
it turns out to be nonlinear how do you
know from that part of the sample okay
so a linear series of points can
generate something nonlinear or it could
be what we have in the fourth graph so
statement is as follows there's one on
one line that could connect series of
dots so we have uniqueness this is why
people like linear models but we're
going to non linear model whatever you
see can be explained by an infinite
number of nonlinear series
or non-linear equations it's infinite so
you realize the explosion of degrees of
freedom which is say that okay we have
in a nonlinear world and so someone's
gonna ask me about basin's of a truck
tractor and chaos theory and stuff like
that I'll talk about it I'm definitely
certain from experience that someone's
gonna ask me about them in this session
so this is why I don't extend I don't
deal with the future the other problem
is it was power loss okay
you only can look at him qualitatively
what we call fractal self-similarity
extremists and as you can say is has one
structure which is a fractal subsidiary
the one that was you know the similar to
the geometry of metal brought the
problem is that reverse engineering the
parameters guess what they're all over
the map it's almost impossible to judge
you can just deal with it qualitatively
but qualitatively we can do very well so
let me conclude here was my what to do
or what not to do I was in essence about
two months ago and I spoke for an hour
and the person told me yeah we've told
us you know now what should we do I had
a cute state I entered the state of Rage
you know that was not really a stone
I've been talking for an hour I would
tell me what not to do and you don't
count it the guy was a consultant and
don't count it as as advice we don't
negative advice to me is vastly more
important than positive advice but
people don't think it is important just
like if you go to the bookstore you can
only learn from people's mistakes you
don't have how I failed in life these
people a cemetery of evidence don't
publish their books okay see how I made
a million times can be accidents but
there's regularity so you see the 10
commandments okay except for for a
couple I think they're negative advice
and look they stuck okay even even
almost the adultery part every day
they've been bit work so advise negative
advice tends to work okay
compared to positive advice okay so I
tell you what not to do
all right what not to do is not to rely
to use forecasts and if
a qualitative way not the reason for an
anxiety relief told you what not to do
throughout so only a charlatan going to
say ten points I'm trying to resist it
because I do not want to be a business
strategy type charlatan was you know ten
steps to success and how to become a
millionaire right so this is why I hate
it and people tell me like I was in
Washington and and someone said well I
got a forecast that my job is to
forecast okay in economic life I told
her what the only thing I can tell you
is I can strongly recommend you get
another job all right
you can't I mean I can't I cannot go in
and solve people's problems I'm not a
dentist you know will you give me your
teeth and tell us problem is I have
general worldview that is and to fit my
worldview I'm a skeptic I'm a skeptical
and persist I cannot
okay tell people what to do right I can
tell people you have to extend tails so
here I'm in a Silicon Valley I can tell
you very easily don't read Harvard
Business School papers typically because
I find mysteries common mistakes and
among all of them they take like the
biotech all right industry and they say
well you know what only one company
makes money if you take out bio engine
or the other engine in tech you know
they don't make money but of course if
you take out the lottery winner a
lottery is so ok the other technique is
an a Black Swan domain conventional
metrics of looking at a pool of results
as indicative of future results is
inherently flawed without extending like
biotech of course is not going to work
okay in small samples okay because the
small sample the past does not have a
cure for baldness for example I know a
few here it definitely makes a company
rich okay if there's a cure for baldness
all right I'm not the only one know
there's some my season shining things in
the crowd so there is so extending into
what you don't know okay so some
industries like biotech venture capital
stuff like that you extend the right
tail in other words if if the Black Swan
happens it can only benefit them
insurance company if a Black Swan
happens it can only hurt them so it's
very simple a rule of thumb of not
trusting returns for banks okay and
under estimating return for venture
capital firms stuff like that small
rules of thumb
also of course not take advice from
someone wearing a tie and stuff like
that okay the and I'm sure people ask me
for more so I'll leave it for the Q&A
another thing I did discover in the
Black Swan is that if we have small
probabilities that have dominated our
planet okay therefore they got to be
survival advantages to those who had
long memory
sure enough there's a paper showing why
Metron had you know that elephants are
Matrimonial the ladies dominate and then
old ladies are kept around guess why
because they remember droughts they
remember what happened in 1906 alright
and why they had to go to find water
okay so remember rare events okay
so there is and societies have used that
for a long time okay Senate for example
Senate - you know it means an old person
okay suppose you have a council of
elders have some you know this is why I
tries to look older than my age with my
grey beard right have conservative but
even in Arabic the term Shae means an
old person alright so there is a value
in society for keeping around people who
are not productive simply as advisors on
rare events
if that happens were to go okay so this
is locally there is something what I
call knowledge without a cause okay
these people have a lot of knowledge
they don't have theories in economics we
have the exact opposite for example we
have crises like the subprime happen we
had the same one eighteen years ago or a
little less okay in 1990 eighteen years
ago Wow time flies it we had the same
one but nobody remembers it because they
simplified two models so they don't
store they so they store the theories
instead of storing the facts which is
what I call every diet and parasitism as
opposed to it without was that inductive
generalization just store the facts and
a theory is destroy that
and finally this okay leads to I was
talking about them precautionary
principle no it's not precautionary
super precautionary principles is giving
some respect to the
just member okay of the planet the
planet itself okay there are some rules
don't mess with complex system because
we don't understand them we don't see a
link between we don't understand what's
going on and the planet is smarter than
us there's a topic of my next book is
how we're lot better at doing that
knowing okay the difference between
explicit and implicit knowledge and
we're better at heuristics than
theorizing theories we do that for
entertainment I think and then we give
to assess illusion like universities
look at the track record they're a lot
better at a PR tell me whether it's cuz
they're not really do anything it's sort
of like you take birds you lecture them
how to fly and then they fly and you
explain you know the miracles of
aerodynamics okay so the yeah so we have
I mean of course they contribute but not
we are a lot better doing why because of
evolution and this is okay this is the
works of evolution alright what we have
on is planet
the result of things have been longer
than us and it knows a lot more than we
do when I go back to the medical
empiricists these people hyper skeptical
but get what one thing they did is they
respected tradition and age and age old
practices even if they didn't make sense
to them in other words you had to have
the default is to go with what was done
rather than you needed to override the
default likewise it leads me to hyper
conservatively called you know approach
to ecology you don't have to explain why
you don't want it to loot you don't want
to explain come up with some theories
particularly if the series can be
fragile to someone like me who can go in
and show how you can you know show
errors and all these forecasting models
to justify not not not polluting okay
thank you very much I think I'm done III
said a lot of things crammed them in 50
slides and thanks
I stay here
we get the house lights up a little bit
so speaker can see the audience we can
see each other see a little more about
the sequence of events in your trilogy
the first book of the book that you
mostly talked about tonight in the next
book
yeah no the first book is not an
interesting book it's called fooled by
randomness but is I wrote it you know
like half when I was half trading half
you know honest when I wanted to kill
time and it was not very deep so I
managed you know what I managed to
rewrite the same book for the Black Swan
nobody I realized not a publisher said
oh it's the same book and I explained to
them that people go to church every
Sunday to listen to the same story
alright so the so I rewrote it I wrote
it in a more intelligent way with the
second one but but and and now I'm
rewriting the whole thing a third time
completely differently as I said
focusing on in like I'm thinking
empiricism to the limit knowledge
without a cause I don't believe in
knowledge and I'm discovering things
after the Black Swan I I met a lot of
people who who gave me evidence that
things like the clinical trials we think
that that's why the person was looking
for in fact no they retrofit their story
and and and and stuff like that so my
next book is going to be the more
drastic drastic you know because I'm
going to make more enemies now already
have only economists as enemies the rest
this is a crowd that's not very hostile
I was tomorrow the house is going to be
very hostile anybody in finance
typically is I mean they have this Phil
tetlock observed he says there's a huge
cognitive how do you call it
dissonance cognitive dissonance
listening to me because either I'm right
and what they're doing is wrong or I
mean you know I gotta be a nut all right
or something like that so they of course
I go for a second option so but they at
the same time they don't feel
comfortable to say well I have no
argument against it so so next time I
think anybody in academia or a lot of
people in academia will have this will
have this you know animosity towards me
yeah what enemies of the current work
surprised you enemies of what sorry of
the current work what who was
scandalized by this book that's correct
well economists because I explained
number one is I use arguments very
simple argument against the science of
economics but by explaining that they're
dangerous to society and stuff like that
and and they're forecasting we rely on
it and and I say okay if you go to
church it's a lot better than listen to
them they got angry and also there are
other things I did with Mandelbrot's we
went into a full pronged attack on
economics established by showing that
the statistics are are off and we went
after the Nobel and now we're going
hunting down the Nobel Committee okay so
so we so these people are not very happy
when we call them charlatans
but I'm explain to me what makes them
different from astrologists there's no
empirically they're the same but there
was also far more elegant right so that
was when we use these arguments I got
very angry let me tell you there's funny
stories I was in Paris at Ecole
Polytechnique where I was speaking and I
stood up and at some point I got
emotional all right
and they were all they're all
mathematician almost and I stood up and
said using these techniques typically
the bell curve to measure risks is not
even silly it's immoral immoral I said
so stop shouting right there's a
gentleman who's from the French edges to
the I'm member of French Academy of
Science and so on it was a scandal so I
had to stop that was that was my best
episode
all right a bunch of quick questions
here I'm able to get quick answers first
ones from Sequoia hacks where is Sequoia
an axe is that a real name probably not
what's going on that's the threshold
between extremists and and mediocrity
and
okay the the that's that's a an
interesting question a lot of people
have dealt with extremists and madeira
stands somewhat in statistical physics
where they you know if people talk about
critical point
bareback spoke about criticality that
generates power laws it's not my point
my point is very simple that Pi Lambda
representation causes me to assume
extremists and as an extension of
unobservable so it's a pistol article I
mean in the end I'm nothing but a
philosopher okay and I'm sceptical
philosopher I cannot use I cannot make a
statement about transition points the
other statement I'd like to make is a
statement about dynamics force
aesthetics people are very good at
trying to explain things using dynamics
because you get tenure by showing
complicated mathematical paper there
have been a lot of papers on the
dynamics that generate extremists and
starting with zhu-li about bacterial
population something called preferential
attachment buys if and assignment right
by a lot of papers showing you know
showing a rich get richer big gets
bigger matthew affects the poor get
poorer because he gives his mind to the
rich okay now all these models are very
simple okay but they don't explain the
world because of Google guys right came
out of nowhere and the big guys tend to
die okay so they can't explain why the
sp500 today only 75 companies survive
the last four years okay if big gets
bigger we should have one big company on
earth okay so what do you have to do to
improve these models is start adding a
twist that makes company and go bust
when you get very big and come back to
my non-linearity now have an infancy
infinitive models and much smaller set
from which to calibrate and it's going
to be difficult here's an Internet
question from Mike
will the internet and internet
connectedness in general bring us more
toward winner-take-all extremists an or
with its empowerment of the amateur more
toward mediocrity unfortunately going
towards winner-take-all extremists an
more and more I'm sorry to say that this
is this is this is life but it's a very
destructive extremist and when I looked
at the the what the Internet has created
is at the same time that it created a
winner-take-all effect it created the
pool of future winners coming to
destabilize the top that's the long tail
of my friend Chris who got me invited
here I mean actually a Philip tetlock
got you and Phil tetlock okay thanks the
the the the idea of having a pool of
people destabilizes so the dynamics are
you more complicated so you have an
extremist and it's not the same winner
every time
now the good look at it look how short
was the road from zero to Alta Vista
back to zero okay and now it was from
zero from college dorm to Google back to
a no sorry so you understand what I mean
by the stable unstable its
extremists and more and more and more
and more unstable do you ever buy stock
no I thought I mean I buy okay but let
me tell you the idea portfolio for
someone who doesn't understand anything
about the world statement I can make is
have the maximum amount of zero
securities and small amount and maximum
risk securities so I have a medium risk
portfolio but I'm not making any claim
okay as to my tail beyond say my loss so
I have a 7% invested that's all I can
lose all right so I'm not making a
statement on future you know and let me
tell you one thing in finance when they
say they can make tail events can
measure tail events when they say a risk
and measure the risks past risk don't
predict future risks that's the first
thing that shocked me
best risks do not predict future risk so
you don't know I mean oh this is all
very verbiage about stock market
measures a risk
speaking of stock markets we had a
question here from Oliver
how do you explain warren buffett's
record this is come back to my picture
of the problem of survivorship bias or
the problem of a cemetery okay I have my
watch even if it's you know a broken
clock can be right twice a day alright
so if you have a lot of investors you're
necessarily it's a necessity to have a
Warren Buffett simply out of luck now
I'm not I don't mean he is lucky I'm
saying I have I'd like to withhold
judgment the only person I say there
only two people I think who are not
lucky there's no luck now I'm not saying
he's necessarily lucky I say I don't
know because randomness you have so many
people trading you necessarily will
produce someone like that the only two
people are Soros but don't tell him all
right and then there is the other
gentleman from Renaissance okay Simon's
he's not he's not lucky beyond he is he
is definitely but what he does he's not
he's not speculator he's just like some
more Walmart stock you know taking
liquidity from one market to the other
there's no exposure to uncertainty in
his models so from max a question is
what does extremists and say about the
power of the individual to influence
events
unfortunately it says two things just
like the same thing as a butterfly you
know the story the butterfly a butterfly
in India flapping its wings it's that's
a metaphor for a chaos theory okay can
generate a you know snowstorm and Tahoe
okay but as it's saying but how many
butterflies are they in India right how
many things like butterflies in India or
snails and Guatemala all right so you
have a lot of small things okay so the I
don't know the problem that you have is
at the individual level
it's a winner-take-all effect so you
have to realize that they have a huge
decoupling between skills skills are
necessary I'm not saying they're not
necessary they're necessary but can lead
you know where an extremist and it would
dentists any medium skilled dentist okay
any dentist can can survive okay but but
in in in I know from writing you have a
million manuscripts of novels floating
around okay I'm sure they're Marvel's in
there
it's extremist and only if you were to
be published that's it
well that may be a little different with
the internet question because the
eyeball issue the books get looked at by
not very bright not right you're right
so outside and stuff in blogs and online
and Kevin Kelly's instead of publishing
a book is doing all this stuff basically
as a sequence of blog items there's a in
Chris Anderson did his book the long
tail pretty much online before he did it
as a book I say so there you're getting
a much larger it's more than a sample
that you're getting a lot of human
intelligence focused on something you're
interested in or making a book which is
both good and popular which is that a
different world I think for nonfiction
and the world of ideas in our world you
probably the online reduce the
randomness of you know if you're smart
how I did my first book football renin
nobody wants to publish it
nobody all right because I have
fictional characters in my book okay and
then you know I have the rejection
letters if you want you know I can you
know show you there's a lot of fun to
read them okay after fact they explain
to you why they're not why it's gonna be
a flop alright and fubar end result
hundreds of thousands copies so the the
I left it on a web and someone picked it
up from the web so so you're right but
it was sort of like an idea book an idea
idea books ideas that they find their
way but novels or nonfiction is not the
same that you have you the the
consciousness our consciousness cannot
Harbor too much too many works of Arts
it's limited that's what creates these
the power loss is too limited our
consciousness is too narrow and getting
narrower is why we have Harry Potter
okay this is a show the English and now
everything is moving to the English
language California something does Cal
for it so ever since concentrating you
see in our knowledge of line of
languages are dying by the minute and
because of extremists an English
winner-take-all they took everything and
it's easier to communicate you know in
the same language yeah you're a polyglot
and I'm sorry ten languages or so I'm
not comfortable in ten languages
whatever it's not that languages don't I
mean you read them you don't use them
but the idea of the first of all
languages survived by luck okay English
is probably the worst possible language
okay so have as world language and it's
becoming nothing it was bad English it
becomes the world language Citibank
English we call the the spreading okay
because of a piece of luck and then
start spreading that's it this is why we
don't have Esperanto sore several
Croatian as the world languages just as
they say the language of science heavily
accented English the but the perspective
you bring has a feeling to me of coming
from enough different angles that your
comfort in a number of different
languages is that some part of your own
mental heuristic that you can think more
strangely than I know it's just
interested in languages because folks
Alan breed I was reading the text ok we
see translations they don't mean the
same thing like for example very simple
stress I mean interests in religion now
and and and if you know a little bit of
Greek you just realize that the credo
doesn't mean I believe in God created be
stable be stable means I just complete
different statements so there's no
statement of belief belief is something
for extremely modern and now is
translate it was translated to belief
so knowing languages sometimes allow you
to see nuances and words Arabic it's
definitely a potent form a lot of the
medieval texts like come from from went
via Arabic will transfer via Arabic and
he had a lot of mistranslation of of
things what's your interest in religion
my interest in oh it's coming my I have
an interest in belief I'm sorry belief
alright belief because I think belief
plays a role mmm okay belief is an
estate for an stamen I think that at the
end I was trying to explain to myself
and shower what was it that I wanted to
do next and try to just realize that
we're not that different from planets
when you go to the zoo except for our
brain and it didn't go very far so I
mean this is I mean you see it in daily
life instead so that's sort of my point
so and and we so this is why I had an
interesting belief is still skin deep
the other problem in evolution is that I
think the mind does not like the vacuum
that our mind doesn't matter
I forgot the there's not like a vacuum
so you instead of religion has worked
I'm conservative has worked for a long
time to fill that vacuum and it works a
lot better than science or science so
you're suggesting that one way of
finessing and a lot of the illusions of
rationality you've been talking about is
basically belief no no my point about no
I'm not I don't recommend but little
additionally I'm saying sorry
tradition with that I'm saying that that
if you remove religion from people's
brains they get into something vastly
worse nationalism could a lot more
people or economics you know something
stuff like so you have so you got
problems so this is my my or social
science or psychoanalysis you see so you
might as well keep them to religion and
it comes back to a statement made that
was the esoteric you know the problem of
agarose which was taken by Spinoza later
I've always said what was he trying to
do was with religion or okay he said
it's very simple if you explain
Aristotle to the common person he or she
won't get it so we got to tell him what
to do therefore the religion place of
all that was either always okay the
biggest thinker of medieval Islam okay
and later on was taken by by Spinoza was
an esoteric
exoteric by saying the Bible is
therefore for a purpose because it's a
good story for people who don't have the
intellect to understand what I
understand you know that was his
statement okay and in different terms of
course so the idea of religion for the
masses all right
the opiate of the masses right as I
remember and said the the stock market
the opiate for the middle class I'd
rather give them back their okay all
right I don't need it but
I'd rather given that opiate and give
him some other you know opiate that
vastly more dangerous that's my that was
my mine but if you can do without this
it's okay if you can all right
odds are people can't raises to the
question how he can be a skeptic without
being a cynic do they go together I
I mean people call me iconoclastic but I
have some huge devotion to some people
like Mandelbrot or some other people so
it's I have different icons cynic I
don't know I mean there's some people I
despise and you say it I'm
uncompromising it's easier to say to
explain uncompromising say these things
the way they are without mincing words
and you stick to it so you get some heat
it's okay alright keep sticking to it
particularly that that I was lucky not
to have been an academic from the start
because when you're I can't even start
you socialized so you're afraid of
offending this guy
I have no allegiance look guys no you
know no even so friends that's okay you
know I give and if I feel guilty to give
money to charity then okay
question from Nicole Boyer how does
focus on black swans affect quality of
decision making does it increase
paralysis or inaction that's exact the
opposite it makes you take a lot more
risk on some domains I take a lot more
risk on some domains if you know if
you're aware of like Swan focus your is
taking on some things not others it
makes you a lot take a lot more risk in
thinker in trial and error and a lot
less risk with when you rely on
someone's opinion who can be for experts
so it's what makes me take a lot more
risk and a lot of drug I think a lot of
a lot of risks I'm not afraid of risks
that some other people are in vice versa
okay
I'm afraid of stock market I don't
understand it I don't think anybody else
does by the way based on track record so
I don't take that risk but there are
other risk I take okay Kevin Kelly
handles the questions she handed me one
by himself
Sheen therapy is a drastic unknown
technology for an example we have
millions of years of experience with
breeding in a sense and maybe eight
thousand years of serious breeding and
zero experience with engineering life so
craig Venter will be here in a couple of
weeks
should we not dare engineer life should
we be do this but don't dare predict it
to see what happens
see predict about possibilities but
don't believe what our predictions say
or D go ahead and predict ok I they're
gonna be dinner no the problem I have is
I cannot I they're so little I know I
only talk about things I know this if
you knew would should we do something in
there I know I have no idea but no I I
think I mean I'm a skeptic and highly
paranoid skeptic alright was things I
don't understand but I don't want to you
know make a statement on the subject but
I'm not familiar with the whole
background I don't know but if you want
to talk about invasions I'd be ready to
talk but not this all right let's go to
one you know Neil Ferguson Peter
Schwartz here has a question Neil
Ferguson with his counterfactual
histories uses multiple interpretations
of histories allowing for invisible
evidence to develop an alternative
scenario said a way of dealing with
black swans yes definitely I he and I
are I mean the same thing if you have
the same he the first person to
understand my book he was the first
person to write about my book and say
this guy I felt understood after reading
him so he understands counterfactual
history alternative scenarios it can
take the visible you have to take
unfeasible what could have happened
let's not stick to the observed but
whenever you have non-observable outcome
wouldn't have happened to have rich
review of history so this is this I
agree my view of counterfactual makes us
even more makes the interpretation of
historical events even more fragile to
error okay then then so it's hard to be
a historian but but I think I agree but
from that step with this counterfactual
yes the introduction of cost factual
probably most this audience is going to
vote tomorrow we're having this election
from the primaries what's looking
statistically at voting which what's
your sense of that's all about III
haven't read the papers not in terms of
outcome just the event itself
what is voting I don't know iiiiii so
little I know all right
but but what I know I know definitely
I'm comfortable with III don't know a
thing about I mean I'm not like a lot of
people ask me about things I know no
clue and and this is it and in one of
thing the Black Swan I say learn have
the guts to say I don't know write this
I know nothing
I definitely not vote for Hillary if you
want my hands that leave John McCain
sorry McCain no I'm not the different I
know I'm not voting for I don't know the
rest
Romney no no no definitely not making a
statement physical statement you can try
you could try all you want just out of
curiosity Longwood I needs real drinks
you know the the ballot is secret but
how many here are voting for Romney Wow
okay good a couple how many for McCain
okay how many for Barack Obama
not surprised how many for Hillary
Clinton about half as many okay so you
see I I would you have predicted that no
no
Ron Paul right ball right in are you
still in it
no definitely I'm not voting for Ron
Paul that's how many here can't vote
that's interesting
Wow okay Thank You Ryan this good
question that's a lot of people I'm
sorry
this is so the lien on the person next
to you and that tells me the proportion
of mathematicians here foreign
mathematicians in the crowd for quantity
so this was wonderful Nicene thank you
so much thanks a lot thanks for inviting
[Applause]
[Music]